a new cbs news battleground tracker poll
shows joe biden with a slight lead in a
key state that president trump won in
2016. the poll shows biden two
percentage points ahead of mr trump
in north carolina we caution that is
within the margin of error for that poll
69 percent of likely voters there say
the supreme court is a major factor in
their vote
and janet chambleen spent the weekend
talking with voters in that key swing
state janet good morning to you
tony good morning north carolina is up
for grabs and the stakes
are high 15 electoral votes that are
pivotal to president trump
especially as he's losing ground in
parts of the midwest
the naming of a supreme court nominee is
having an impact here
it's a motivating factor for voters on
both sides
from universities in the research
triangle to the appalachian mountains
to its craggy coastline north carolina
has always been a study in contrast
personally i'm supporting donald trump
mine biden biden
this year it's the political landscape
that's never been more diverse
it's changed drastically with population
and
all the people coming in jobs reportedly
more than 1.3 million
new registered voters since the 2016
race
like yuffie wu my friend told me north
carolina is a swing state so my vote
counts
so yeah i'm getting old most newcomers
are registering as unaffiliated with
either party
a block that could sway the election a
third of the state's voters are
independent
like kathy martin who's going to mail in
her ballot
there's a lot of independents like me
who might have voted for trump last time
who are going to vote biden this time
because of what trump has done from
rural farmers markets
to in-town fish fries the talk now is of
the supreme court nomination
and how it's amplified the election this
is the most important election that i've
ever had in my whole life
vivian thomas mccoy will take her
frustration to a polling place
i think he should wait like the lady on
her dying bed
asked him to do wait and then put
he whoever the president is whether it's
him or biden
then that person be put in the office
because they wouldn't let obama do that
deborah bledsoe is a trump supporter who
opposes abortion
there's no reason to block that if
they're a good person and
they are a lawyer and they know the law
and they're going to follow the law
at a world driving church service
christopher burwell says he's concerned
about what he's heard
she will do away with
obamacare she will do away with
roe versus wade in the sprint to
election day
the president has made five trips here
in four weeks
joe biden visited last week and kamala
harris will be here today
those visits happening as week to week
coronavirus cases are on the rise
i'm going to get this for my daughter
the deciding factor
for teresa costanzo mainly the virus
how that's been handled i know that i
can't even get a test even if i want a
virus test
i have not been able to get one the
changing colors of a battleground state
bluer cities suburbs and the areas
around them
rural areas turning redder
there's another critical race here and
that is for the senate republicans
desperately need incumbent tom tillis to
win
to help them retain control of the
senate but tillis is in a dog fight
the latest cbs news battleground tracker
shows tillis
trailing his democratic challenger cal
cunningham
by 10 points so north carolina guys
is definitely an important state for
both parties
anthony yeah and it's very close in the
presidential race janet thank you so
much